[Musique]
pourquoi encore alors on se remet des
programmes aux autres saluent maroni est
bien là je vais renconter joannie il va
nous parler du dispositif pass loisirs
jeux parisiens volontaires fonctionne et
qui peut en bénéficier
justement je vais dénicher toutes les
infos à plus tard maroni si vous aussi
le pass loisirs vous intéresse
suivez-moi
[Musique]
comme son nom l indique le pass loisirs
permet de pratiquer des activités dans
divers domaines chez les prestataires
affiliés au dispositif pass du conseil
départemental
ce dispositif est destiné aux personnes
en situation de handicap reconnu ayant
des droits ouverts et à jour auprès de
la mdph grâce à cette aide du
département les bénéficiaires peuvent se
rendre au musée au cinéma et même chez
le coiffeur à 37 ans je manie boyer ne
s'en prive pas et il a bien raison allez
on va tout de suite à sa rencontre
[Musique]
bonjour jovani toit de quelle manière ce
que tu utilises c'était du département
pour des activités pour les loisirs le
week-end comme le bowling le cinéma où
aller au théâtre pour aller au musée
mori techart l'isaf à l'hôtel ici et
c'était du département ce chèque loisirs
tu l'a découvert de quelle manière quand
je travaillais à les apprivoiser
comme je suis porteur d'un handicap
c'est une bonne chose pour les personnes
qui ont des difficultés pour faire des
loyers commence à lui faire les
démarches pour la voir mais comme on a
des problèmes pour ses démarches
administratives sont en difficulté cu
est occupée pour faire les démarches
pour moi les assurés dans le mercier
joignant
cinéma coiffeur hôtels ou encore clubs
sportifs en tout ce sont plus de 200
partenaires qui dispose de l'agrément du
département le pass loisirs permet ainsi
aux bénéficiaires de s'ouvrir au monde
et à ses activités et ça fonctionne à
travers toute l'île
bonjour valérie une motion alexandre
alors dites nous comment peut-on
bénéficier de ce patio azur pour
bénéficier de ce pass choisir il faut
être qu'une personne porteuse d'un
handicap avoir des droits pour veiller à
ce jour auprès de la maison
départementale de la personnes
handicapées mdph ou allons de la cgss
pour une pension d'invalidité de
catégorie 2 ou 3 et 7 heures du
département sous quelle forme elle se
présente alors elle se présente sous
forme d'un chèque à hauteur de 210 euros
l'année avec des feuilles de chèque de 5
euros ces chèques ils pourront les
utiliser à quel endroit les
bénéficiaires peuvent les utiliser chez
l'un des prestataires agréés à ce
dispositif dans le domaine des activités
sportives culturelles comme le cinéma le
théâtre coiffeur ouais merci beaucoup
valérie pieve un prix
depuis près de vingt ans ce dispositif
vient en aide aux personnes porteuses de
handicap comme giovanni les
bénéficiaires peuvent sortir de chez eux
et pratiquer des activités sportives ou
culturelles il leur suffit de présenter
leurs chèques aux partenaires affiliés à
ce dispositif alors le faso a dit à
l'ats était-il c'est à l'epo oui et est
ce que pour l'année 2022 ou là bien film
trop nouvellement ou wifi j'ai fait le
renouvellement bien comme il faut
tourner c'est beaucoup et on voit le
voilier merci moi je vous remercie
si vous souhaitez en savoir davantage
sur le pas ce plaisir n'hésitez pas les
coordonnées s'affiche en ce moment même
sur votre écran le département des
générations c'est déjà fini si vous
souhaitez revoir cet épisode ainsi que
les précédents rendez vous sur nos sites
et nos réseaux sociaux quant à moi je
vous retrouve très vite pour un nouvel
épisode à bientôt
la semaine prochaine nous allons aider
prouver à la ceni une carte bien
pratique destiné aux personnes âgées ou
en situation de handicap grâce à ce
dispositif
elles sont plus invités les places de
parking dans les bus et même dans les
files d'attenté
[Musique]